Hallo Wolfgang.
Hallo Stefan.
Wie hast du die Woche verbracht?
Doch recht viel vor den Nachrichten. Du auch?
Bisschen.
Ja schon.
Ich bin jetzt nicht wach geblieben bis 2 Uhr nachts, aber ja.
Ich auch nicht. Das zeichnete sich ja dann doch am späten Abend ab, dass irgendwie miteinander geredet wird. Ich bin schockiert darüber, dass man von der Bundesregierung eigentlich nichts dazu gehört hat, dass Donald Trump dort verkündet, eine Zivilisation auszurotten. Und der einzige höherrangige Politiker, der aber ein Politiker AD ist, der sich dazu kritisch äußert, ist Peter Altmaier, der quasi aus dem Ruhestand heraus bei Twitter mal schreibt, dass das so nicht geht.
Bei Twitter?
Und sonst gibt es dazu eigentlich gar nichts. Es ist so skandalös, und dass überhaupt die Situation entstehen konnte, dass man also nicht vorher von Seiten der EU und von Seiten vor allem der Bundesrepublik sich vehement gegen Trumps Kurs und auch gegen Netanyaus Kurs gestellt hat. Und Netanyau ja immer noch gewähren lässt, der jetzt ja gerade dabei ist, den Libanon Stück für Stück dem Erdboden gleich zu machen, ist für mich skandalös. Also ich finde da kaum Worte für.